twin gallon weaver is one of the top
leaders of India's biggest armed group
the nationalist Socialist Council of
nagaland Issac Weaver at 85 many think
he's the man most capable of sealing a
political deal with the government a
deal that's been 22 years in the making
in 2015
Narendra Modi's government and the rebel
group signed a framework agreement and
the talks now appear to be the final
stages all nos will have to be in the
Indian Union that is what they told us
now sorry we rejected but there's a
problem our institution will have to be
ours your concision will be yours and
our flags will have to be ours your flex
will have to be your flex but they are
finding the fever no no the Nagas armed
group has up to 5,000 fighters and runs
its own pilot government the issue of
territorial and political sovereignty
for the Nagas has been at the heart of
the conflict since India's independence
Nagas want what they call Nagaland or a
homeland consisting of nagaland
parts of three Indian states and some
areas in Myanmar but some groups are
also calling for a more practical
solution
you know fail ELISA vane who belongs to
a separate coalition of seven split Naga
armed groups also in talks with the
government I don't know why Constitution
has been always been mentioned about us
unless you know any country nation it's
not declared as a nation how can you
have a constitution Nagaland became part
of the Indian Union in 1963 other Nagas
inhabited areas are split between three
other Indian states they celebrate
Independence Day one day before India
does they don't pay taxes to the
government but different groups fighting
for their cause but that system has
crippled Naga lands infrastructure and
choked its economy in today's reality
many educated youths
are suffering because of this economic
conditions people are frustrated so
peace talks are critical but the Indian
government's decision to revoke ashbey's
autonomy is also casting a shadow you're
taking away autonomy from Jammu and
Kashmir or have taken it away and you're
promising it to the Nagas so what value
does that promise have for the Nagas and
this is what is impacting the talks the
governor of Rockland has told in the
media that talks are stuck on the
symbolic issues of flag and the
Constitution but after decades of
fighting the Nagas are still waiting for
a settlement that fully respects ties to
their land the history and identity
Priyanka Gupta al Jazeera camp heparin
Nagaland